>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.,
>> Good afternoon.
I'm John Haskell, Director
of the Kluge Center.
On behalf of the center's staff,
I want to welcome those of you
who are not library employees
to The Library of Congress.
This event is part of
the Center's effort
to bring cutting edge
research to policymakers,
and the interested public.
This is in keeping with
the Kluge Center's mission
since its inception in 2000.
The notion, according to John
Kluge, the late John W. Kluge,
is to "have a space at
the library to bring doers
and thinkers together."
Today, we have one
of those thinkers,
a scholar in residence, Digital
Studies fellow, Dr. Todd Belt.
He is here to answer questions
for me, and a little later
from you, about the impact
of social media on
American politics.
Let me tell you a little bit
about Todd before
we get started.
Todd joined us at
the Kluge Center
from his home institution the
University of Hawaii at Hilo.
He will be going to
Colorado now, for the break,
and then to get really cold
weather, before he goes back
to work in the spring semester.
He is a professor of
Political Science there.
His research and writing focuses
on the Presidency, mass media,
public opinion, and
campaigns and elections.
He is co-author of four books,
over two dozen articles,
and over a dozen chapters
and edited volumes.
His most recent publication,
which was completed
this year here
at the Kluge Center is entitled,
Can We At Least All
Laugh Together Now?
Twitter and Online Political
Humor During the 2016 Election.
It appears in the book,
The Role of Twitter
in the 2016 U.S. Election, which
was just published this month.
Of course, afterward Todd can
tell us more about that book,
and Todd, let me start with kind
of just a softball question
before I get tough on you.
>> All right.
>> As a student of American
politics, how did you get
into the study of social media?
>> Well, I wrote my doctoral
dissertation on the influence
of text, visual and
audiovisual messages,
and I was really interested
in how those had a differential
impact on persuading people how
to vote, and how they thought
about political issues,
and during that time the
net revolution happened
in the mid-1990s,
to date myself.
And I was really
influenced by how
so much more media
was available.
Then of course, we had the
social medial revolution
in the early 2000s, and
now anybody can create
and disseminate all this
type of information,
which has really changed
our information environment,
in which we're doing governance.
And I think it is a very
important question for us
to address as we forge ahead
in our great experiment
in popular government.
>> So you must have been on
kind of-- you were the vanguard,
part of the vanguard of
scholars, is that right?
In this area?
>> I guess [laughs].
There's a bunch of people who--
>> Couldn't have
any in the 90s...
>> There's a bunch of people
who have been working on this,
and I'm among them, but
there's a lot of people
who have done quite
a lot of research
that I'll talk about today.
>> Okay. While you've been
here at the library this year,
what exactly have
you been doing?
You know, how did you make
use of library collections,
you know, what kind of research
were you conducting here?
>> Yeah, my research project was
on how the digital revolution
has changed how we conceive
of Presidential candidates, and
looking at a longitudinal study
from the modern Presidential
campaign from 1960 onward
to current, and comparing how
people express themselves,
and how they interacted with
the information environment,
both before and after
we have social media.
>> Okay. So now we're going
to get to the substance
of the matter, and I think
it's good, it's always good
in an academic setting to make
sure we know what we're talking
about, kind of definitionally.
>> Sure.
>> Let's just make sure we're
all-- what is the distinction,
what is social media as
compared to regular media?
Where is the line drawn?
>> Okay. Well as I
mentioned before,
we talked about the first
internet revolution,
we have what we consider sort
of three different stages,
what we call legacy media, this
is the good old days, right?
When we had three television
networks, newspapers, and radio
and such, and then we started
to get our cable
television networks.
Then we have web 1.0, which is
the first internet revolution.
We started getting web pages.
And that was distinguished
by the fact
that it was what you would
call a one to many sort
of relationship, whereas you
would have certain people
putting up websites, had
the ability to do so,
was still pretty onerous
to do it back then.
And being able to talk to
people through websites,
and later on some
blogs and stuff.
Now, there were some people
who were putting up websites,
and communicating with other
people through Usenet groups
and things, but that
was a smaller fraction.
What really happened with
what we called web 2.0,
the term of the millennium,
was the ease
with which you could create
internet content became
drastically reduced.
Much cheaper, much easier, you
could put together websites.
Somebody would have
something that, you know,
pre-programmed website, just
put your content in there,
it comes out all nice, and
people can interact with it.
And out of that, sprang
what we call social media.
And social media now allows
us to interact with people
that we know socially and people
that we don't know socially
and where there's overlaps, you
can reach and get your message
to people that you
wouldn't normally talk to.
They may not be on your
email distribution list.
They may not just happen
by your website by chance.
And so because of social media,
this is how we've had this big
expansiveness, of being able
to contact one another.
And so now that's what we call
the many to many relationship.
It has really caused
a democratization
of the information environment
for political discourse,
for better or worse.
>> So, this may be an
unsophisticated question,
but a blog on the Washington
Post, where does that fall
on the line, is that legacy?
Or is that social media?
>> Well, now because we are in
the social media environment,
it becomes more legacy that is
linked through social media.
It gets recirculated through
social media, through linking,
through Twitter, Twitter
accounts, and Facebook.
So it's all very much
linked together now.
>> Yeah, so it's hard to--
sometimes hard to make that
distinction all that fast.
>> Yeah, and of course
people can post comments
on certain things, and--
>> Exactly, yeah, that's kind
of what I was getting at,
and even on normal articles,
it can be a blog, right?
>> Sure.
>> In the political context,
what effects do social
media have on individuals?
>> The main effect that social
media has on individuals
that has really changed how we
go about getting information
and what we consider to be
valid information, there is 81%
of Americans now have some
sort of social media presence.
That doesn't mean
they're using it,
some people will create
something and not go back to it.
But of that 81%, about
two-thirds of people say
that they go online for
information about politics.
So social media, when
it comes to politics,
is mainly about information,
and learning
about what is going
on in the world.
And it has had a number of
effects on people's attitudes
and behaviors, in terms of just
even their policy positions,
20% of Americans have said
that through their interactions
in social media, they've
changed an opinion on an issue.
And 17% have said that
they changed their opinion
about a political candidate.
So it really does have some
important ramifications there.
But of course, there is
all this information.
And another thing that
we're really seeing is a lot
of fatigue.
Over two-thirds of people
say that they are "worn out"
by the amount of
politics on social media.
We really have become
this information
overload environment.
Many people have said
that they do not--
many people say the social
media has created an environment
which is now more toxic
for political discussions.
More than half say
that they think
that social media discussions
are more angry, less tolerant,
and less informative
than political discussions
they have elsewhere.
And so we see a lot of
people are now blocking a lot
of people, and not
following other people.
A quarter of Americans say
that they just won't have
any interaction with people
because of something they've
posted on social media
with which they disagree.
And yet people still
come back to it, right?
We have this addiction.
Social media is a
heck of a drug.
And we do keep coming
back to it.
And part of that is because we
have this need and this longing
to make sure that what we say
is important to other people.
We get a lot of validation
by having what we say be
important to other people.
In fact, when you get a ring
on your phone, a text message,
or even just an alert
about a media post,
or someone has responded to
your post, some people say
that actually releases
dopamine into your brain,
and you get a little
high out of it.
And so it is something that
is extremely addictive.
>> It's better for you
than some other similar--
>> Yeah, and there are some
behavioral effects, too, right?
Protests, and in elections...
>> So I know of a
fairly rich literature
that developed some years
ago as, you know, Fox News,
the advent of Fox News, and then
later on MSNBC, about whether,
you know, that style of media,
that sort of ideological media,
was making people, you know,
more liberal or conservative.
And some of that literature
is counter-intuitive.
My question for you though, in
the social media context is,
so is it making, you know,
moving people to the left
or right or both, you know?
>> Yeah, there's a real
big chicken and egg problem
with doing that kind
of research, right?
Because people tend to
seek out what they like.
One of the things that we
know is that people have,
one of the things I wanted
to talk about is the fact
that we do have tendency for
confirmation bias, right?
That is, we will believe
information that corresponds
to our pre-existing
notions, and we also engage
in what is called motivated
reasoning, and behaviors
where we will go out
and find information
that will help us avoid
what psychologists call
cognitive dissonance.
That is, if I hear something bad
about the candidate that I like,
I will try to find
information that will discount
that information, right?
And so there is some
information that does happen.
But I've got some graphics
that will show you how this is
really played out in the 26th--
>> So here's my hardball
question for you.
Can social media actually change
the outcome of an election?
>> Okay, I don't want to
sound like I'm hedging
on this one again [laughter],
but this is a tough one, right?
To try to say to somebody
did you change your opinion
because of what you
saw on social media?
A lot of people are not
going to answer that question
in the affirmative, right?
And can we go back and look at
everybody's social media history
and then find out
how they voted?
Well there is also
again a chicken
and egg problem there too
because we know people follow
people they like, right?
That they already agree with.
So it is difficult for us.
We are having a problem
with the computer, John?
Thank you.
Always updating,
right [laughter].
Also--
>> 2.0, right?
>> [Laughs] Yeah.
The chicken and egg problem
also with trying to find out,
you know, where people sharing
with others, but we do know
that some of what we call
instrumental variables,
that is things that help
candidates get elected are
impacted by social media.
In fact, people more
like to volunteer,
to share the candidate's
information,
get out the vote efforts, seem
to be enhanced by social media.
Campaign contributions are
enhanced by social media,
and a number of other factors
that do help get
candidates elected.
We are more sure that
certainly does help.
>> Yeah, you sort
of have that path.
So this is going to be back
to basics, for those of us
who are more unsophisticated
about the impact
of social media.
The words "fake news" out
there all the time, of course,
can you tell us exactly how
social media spread fake news?
Is there an easy way just to
explain that, for those of us
who are less sophisticated?
>> Two very important terms,
virality, and velocity.
And if we look at what we
call virality, that has to do
with sort of the logarithmic
rate of growth of sharing
of information that
happens in social media.
This is just something I did
back in the 2008 election,
looking at the viral videos
that came out with Barack Obama,
and back then it was candidate
Mitt Romney, and as you can see,
some of them hit over 20
million views, whereas a lot
of them are languishing
in the mere 2 million
views, and what happens?
What happens is, you catch fire.
You get to that critical mass
where people start
sharing your information,
not just with people they
know, but across platforms.
And that is what we
call the velocity.
Velocity is movement
across platforms.
You can see I did a logarithmic
transformation on it.
It resembles sort of a normal
curve, once you see that,
once you ramp it up, and
you can really catch fire.
So that's a big part of it.
So how do you get to
that critical mass?
And how do you get
something to catch fire?
And why is it the fake news
people have figured this
out more than others?
Right? A lot of it has
to deal with what we call
in political science,
moral contagion.
And that is something
becomes contagious
when it has a moral
content to it.
When you use moral
language especially language
that is emotionally
charged, and moral,
you can usually get a bump of
about at least 20% in the amount
of people who are going to
recirculate your information.
So that is a really big thing.
And so of course, the people we
might call bad actors out there
in the world, that are
spreading fake information,
they know that too.
And so you can see that a lot
of the stuff has been
recirculated are not necessarily
things that say vote one
way or vote another way,
but really designed to drive
a wedge into the public
and the united states,
really trying
to divide us as a country.
A lot of stuff for and
against Black Lives Matter,
for and against Muslims,
this came up with the issue
of President Trump re-tweeting
the videos that turned
out to be fake in the UK.
So that is something that, you
know, once we get ramped up,
we can reach that critical
mass, and then you get
to this aspect of
confirmation bias.
And so people want to
believe what they see.
Then you get into somehow
stimulate this feed algorithm.
Right? These are
some of the elements
of Facebook's feed algorithm.
I'm not asking you to read all
of them or anything like that,
there's no test on this, right?
But you can see that
it's based upon a number
of different things.
And they change this on a weekly
basis as to what is important.
But if you notice that it's,
are you linking to other things?
Are your shares liked
by other people?
It's built into this equation
that if you get something
that starts to move, it's going
to snowball pretty quickly
and move around the internet.
So it's also helped by the fact,
fake news is helped by the fact
that we have a natural
psychological human tendency
to like to tell people
something new, something novel,
to get the scoop on the
newest, latest information,
to regale our friends
with information
that might be counter intuitive.
That they might not expect.
Oh, hey, this is actually
the way this works,
not the way you thought.
And so we have a
tendency to do that.
And that plays into it.
So what I'm telling
you is, social media,
such as it is structured, plays
into our worst human tendencies
to share biased information.
And so you know,
this is what we get.
We have people who
want to believe,
and then are sharing
the information.
>> We have an astrobiology
share as well--
>> We do.
>> I think that was mistakenly
in here from her talk,
I think [laughter], the--
so, of course, not all
social media platforms are
created equal.
And we are-- I assume not.
Are there differences
among them in terms
of their impact on politics?
>> Yeah, and a lot of it
has to do with their nature.
Twitter famous for its 140
characters, now 280 characters.
You can't do much of
a policy discussion
at 140 characters right?
But you can link
to stuff outside,
and there's also differences
in the profiles of the people
who use them, and the ways that
they're used by politicians.
We find that politicians have a
tendency to use Twitter to speak
to the press, whereas they use
Facebook more as a tendency
to organize supporters, and
that has to do with the fact
that Twitter is a little
bit more professional,
a little bit more geared
toward the press, mass media.
And Facebook is geared
more toward, you know,
what people want to do,
and what they're doing
at that particular moment.
And so you know, that's also
played out in just, you know,
on Facebook you friend somebody,
whereas on Twitter
you follow somebody.
I mean, those words are
actually kind of true.
>> So this is a little-- still
talking about the platforms
and the differences among them,
but a little different angle.
What, if anything, are the
different platforms doing
to tamp down the
spread of fake news?
>> Right. Well we certainly
don't want to try to force them
to do anything, having the First
Amendment being such as it is,
and also social media
platforms are very popular,
so it probably wouldn't
be a good way to try
and start legislating
against them.
But some of the things
that they're going
after are what we call
the dark ads, right?
These are some of
the advertisements
that come from other places.
You may have heard
during the 2016 election,
there was $100,000 in
Rubles paid to Facebook,
coming from a dot-RU
address, well you know,
that's got fingerprints all over
it, so that's pretty obvious.
But there are some things that
are a little bit less obvious,
and there are a number
of different projects
that researchers are working on,
trying to identify bots
a little bit better.
Right? And bots are those
automated algorithms
that generate and distribute
content a little bit different
than what we call cyborgs, and
cyborgs are ones that are sort
of human is using it and
tweaking it a little bit to try
to get better distribution.
So right now, Facebook is
working with Pro Publica,
in order to try to identify some
of those dark ads
that are coming in.
Facebook tried to create what
they called a disputed indicator
tag, and they were
working with a number
of the fact check groups.
Factcheck.org, and such,
problem was you know,
it takes about three days
to fact check something.
And by that time, your virality
and velocity is already
over, right?
When something catches fire,
and you know, it catches an air
of truth to it, so that's
a little bit difficult.
Now they've got something
called a trust indicator
that they're putting next to
little ads with the little I
that you can put
your mouse over,
and then you can get a
little bit of information,
but it's not quite known
whether or not that's going
to be particularly effective.
It just gives you information
about who put that ad there.
So it's difficult,
you know, the--
we always say the hackers are
one step ahead, and it's true
that they are, so it's
difficult to keep that up.
In terms of more
public information,
there is an Oxford project
on computational propaganda,
which is just an awesome word.
I love that.
Computational propaganda.
But they're doing a lot of
research on social media,
and trying to identify
things, trends that are going,
and trying to identify what
the next trend is going to be,
that we can impact what we
see in here in social media.
>> Let's switch gears
a little bit.
You know, we're right across
the street from the Capitol,
and all the House and Senate
office buildings, and I know one
of the challenges,
you know, I've been in
and around Congress for,
I guess decades now.
And in terms of managing social
media, as a practical matter,
how should-- maybe you can
be a little prescriptive,
or at least throw
out some ideas.
How should Congressional
offices handle social media
so that things, for
lack of a better term,
don't spiral out of control?
>> Right. Well, politicians
really love social media.
Because it helps them avoid
what they call the media filter.
Right? They don't have
to go through the news,
and have what they're
saying edited,
or in some ways constrained.
So they can get all of
their message out there,
without having to
go through editors.
But there is also the saying,
you know, the old saying,
never pick a fight with somebody
who buys ink by the
barrel, right?
When talking about
the old newspapers,
and Congressmen's
relationships with them,
should say Congress-persons now.
And...everybody has
got the ink now, right?
Everybody has got a chance
to, you know, there are people
on Twitter who have
millions of followers,
and they're not politicians,
they're not celebrities,
they're people who have just
really become the go-to people,
that people look toward for
comment on what's going on.
So you have to be
kind of careful.
But there is some political
science information that says
that in terms of speaking
with constituents,
you have to realize that
there are different types
of constituents.
There are some who are more
informed with what is going on,
and there are some who are
a little bit less informed.
And the ones who are a
little bit more informed,
it is usually better to
use data, and numbers,
and to give them the
information they need
to know about a policy.
But for less informed voters,
it's better to tell a story.
Using a narrative.
Using emotional language, you
can actually get more traction
with those people by telling
a story, kind of the way
that Reagan used to, when
he used to tell his stories.
And you can also
create interactivity.
Many of you have
probably seen on Twitter,
you have your little Twitter
poll, and stuff, right?
People actually like those.
They like to engage with those.
So people will sometimes share
those polls, and another thing
that gets a lot of
re-tweeting on Twitter is
when you have contests, little
contests, who can name this?
And that gets people
involved as well.
And asking people questions.
But that can backfire on
you spectacularly as well.
So when you ask the public
a question, be aware that,
you know, the other side is
going to come after you on that.
I mean, I think of Jeff
Lake, last week, right?
He gave a contribution to Roy
Morris' competitor, Doug Jones,
and you know, he just took
a picture of it right?
And he said party over country.
And that just totally went
viral because, because of that.
It was something that people
didn't expect, it was quick,
it had an emotional sort of
appeal to it, and the last thing
that people need to do to
get a lot of traction is
to do what we say go external.
One of the things that really
hampered Hillary Clinton's
online campaign in 2016 was
that of all of her Tweets,
75% of them that had external
links went back to her website
or other social media platforms,
whereas 75% of Donald
Trump's went elsewhere,
which meant that he
was expanding his web
and his networks
throughout the campaign,
whereas Hillary Clinton
was constraining hers.
>> You know, kind of from a
similar practical standpoint,
at least, what do citizens need
to know to protect themselves
or better inform themselves
about what is going on?
Protect themselves
from fake news?
>> Well, it's difficult, right?
Because it's all over the place,
and the fact checkers
are three days behind,
and it's difficult to know.
>> I'm going to interrupt
you there--
>> Please do.
>> That raises something,
you know,
you read the Washington
Post has the fact checker,
and then there is the
organization, I think from out
of St. Petersburg does it.
>> Yeah, mm-hmm.
>> And do those have impact?
>> Mm-hm.
>> I mean, are they
making a difference?
Or is having, you know, like
the Washington Post has the
four Pinocchio's--
>> Right.
>> Is that too confusing
or what?
I mean, you get the drift
of what I am asking.
>> Yeah, it's pretty marginal,
but what political science
research has shown is
that if you can re-tweet that
information in such a way
that makes it funny or
humorous, you can use humor
to attract attention
to someone's falsehood.
That can be more informative
than just the information
itself.
>> Just the fact.
>> It's how you package it
that really matters, yeah.
And so recognizing and knowing
what is fake is a difficult
thing to do, but one of
the things that we saw,
let me go to it here,
this is a crazy spider web
that was created by Yochai
Benkler up at Harvard and MIT,
about the 2016 election,
and [sneezes] excuse me,
you will see that Breitbart
became sort of the center
of the shared universe
on Facebook and Twitter,
during the 2016 election.
That the stories that were
there, these web links
and the sizes indicate how
much content was linked
to from those sources.
And on the right side you
can see Washington Post,
New York Times, CNN, and
a lot of those stories
on Breitbart were re-written
by bots with headlines
that would be very
controversial,
which didn't even match
the content of the story.
So one of the things you
have to do is you have
to read the stories, right?
There's a saying on the
internet, TLDR, right?
Too long, didn't read it.
Right? So a lot of people
will share stories just
because they read the
headline, it corresponds
with something they want to
say, and having it seem to come
from ostensibly a credible
source makes them want
to share it to get their
political point out.
So reading things
through is very important.
Recognition.
There are some places on the
web that you can go to and check
that are a little bit more
helpful, and there is,
all right, Snopes is
a good one, as well,
and Hoaxy is another one.
And so Twitter and
Facebook are trying
to provide more credibility
to certain people,
you get your little blue
checkmark, right, on Twitter,
although that has become
very controversial as to
who gets that, and to
who is considered an
authoritative figure.
So there are certain
things you can do.
But the first thing is read
the whole thing, right?
See if it makes sense.
Does it pass the smell test?
Right?
>> So kind of get into some
wrap-up questions, you know,
in an attempt to
bring together some
of the things you've
talked about,
and whatever else would make
sense, from your perspective
and being immersed in
cutting edge scholarship,
and doing the scholarship
yourself on social media
and politics, can you identify
a few of the biggest problems
that you would see as problems?
>> Yeah. The biggest
problem is, as I like to say,
we have met the enemy
and he is us.
Right? Social media is a tool,
and it's how we have interacted
with this tool, and like I
said, it's brought out some
of our naturally
occurring tendencies
that are really difficult.
We need to catch up
to this technology
in terms of the way we use it.
I mean, we sprung
into this headlong
without really thinking too
much about what we're doing.
It's been ready, fire,
aim, instead of ready, aim,
fire, with social media.
And so we need to
recognize and come to grips
with what we can do
to be better citizens,
to pass along information
that is more verifiable,
and to use it in
a responsible way.
We have to recognize that we
have a natural human tendency
to do public performances
of our allegiances,
that is to use social media
not to say what I think,
but what I want you
to think who I am.
Right? And to create this
social media platform of this,
this is who I am for the
world to consume, right?
This is what I want
people to think of me.
Which means that you end up
sometimes sharing information
that may not be exactly
what has--
as honest as it could
otherwise be.
We also have to come to grips
with the fact that, you know,
familiarity can sometimes
breed contempt,
and there are things sometimes
people will say to each other
when they feel familiar
with them,
and behind their
keyboards, safe and secure.
And say things that are,
you know, can be hurtful.
There is that shield that
the internet provides
that social media can
at times bring out some
of our worst tendencies.
And I think the last thing that
we really need to come to grips
with in terms of using
social media is our tendency
to read the worst motivations
in what other people post.
And we do this all the time.
Specifically when it's text.
We have a tendency
to think, you know,
the person has the worst motive,
or they're out to get us,
when they may just
be asking a question.
We think it's a rhetorical
question, it's a snide remark.
And so dealing with our
own issues is, I think,
a really big part of that.
>> So I don't want to be droll,
but what is the plus side?
>> Oh, absolutely there are
many plus sides to it, right?
The plus sides, obviously
for members of Congress
and presidents, they can
talk directly to the people
and avoid the media, for
better or worse, right?
Like I said.
The internet has also allowed us
to, you know, not allow people
to run away from
their pasts, right?
We're seeing a lot of that now,
that things will come
back to catch you.
And it used to be
that politicians used
to have what some
people would consider
to be a throwaway
line about policy.
If they didn't know what to
do about a political issue,
they would say well, we have
to have a national dialogue
about this issue, we need
to have a national
dialogue about race.
We need to have a national
dialogue about sexual assault.
Well, guess what?
We're having those.
And why are we having those?
Because this tool social
media has allowed these voices
that have otherwise
not been heard.
A place to be expressed.
And so issues of sexual
harassment, and sexual assault,
the Black Lives Matter
movement, other issues
that otherwise may
not have been covered
in main steam press are
now pushed into the foray,
so much so now that, you know,
you have our Times
Person of the Year, right?
They're the silence breakers.
>> So this is the your final
jeopardy, really, hard question.
On balance, does social
media help or harm democracy?
>> Can I say the
jury's out [laughter]?
I don't want to hedge
or anything like that,
but certainly there
are some drawbacks,
and I think I've highlighted
a lot of them that have
to do with, you know,
our human psychology.
But there are also a
lot of benefits, right?
More information ostensibly
is good for democracy, right?
But of course, we
have to be able
to tell what is good information
from bad information,
and we have to be able to
speak with one another, right?
And social media allows us
to speak with one another.
We have been yelling at one
another, instead of speaking
with one another, right?
We've been attacking each other,
instead of having
a civil dialogue.
And if we can get to that point
where we can have a more
civil dialogue back and forth,
then I think the benefits
will outweigh the drawbacks
that we've seen so far.
I mean we used to have this
system, the legacy media,
where you had the three
television networks
that were controlling most
of what people saw and heard,
and now we have so
many perspectives.
Has the pendulum swung too far?
Becoming polarized?
It's not so bad to
become polarized
and have more perspectives,
as long as we can discuss
things with civility.
>> You know, you raise--
people my age, and you know,
the baby boom, which of
course the lump in the snake,
so there's more than any
other group [chuckling],
the baby boom grew up
you know, as though,
and I guess the sense was,
it was always the three
networks, and that was it.
That must be the, you
know, the load star,
or whatever that expression is.
>> Right.
>> That must be the goal, that's
the right way, but in fact,
you know, we may think the
social media age is crazy,
but the anomaly was that
period for a few decades
when TV existed and there
were only three networks,
and you capture news from
three sources, and you know,
and 63 people watch the
news hour, you know,
and then before that,
it was a different kind
of free-for-all wasn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> So it isn't like, you know,
we should think about oh,
it's bad, because when
Walter Cronkite told us what
to think was a better time,
because there was another period
that had some serious
drawbacks, too.
>> I'm not saying it's better,
and I'm not saying its worse.
I'm saying there are pluses
and negatives involved.
>> Kind of a perspective on it.
>> Yeah.
>> Well thank you, Todd.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Very interesting.
>> Right.
[ Applause ]
>> We are prepared to
entertain questions.
Raise your hands, and we want
to, there is a gentleman--
there's a few, where
are our microphones?
Got you. Emily have you got it?
This gentleman here
in the front, center.
>> I realize everything is
complex, but when you look back
in history, blacks and women
struggled for decades to achieve
at least some degree
of legal equality.
>> Yes.
>> The gay movement
moved much quicker.
Did social media have
any role in that?
>> Yes. I do believe that
social media has had a role
in the interactions
with-- that people have.
One of the things
that we can see
about the gay rights movement,
that allowed it to swing
so quickly in the
period of 8 years, right?
You had two-thirds against,
versus two-thirds for,
gay marriage right?
In the period of eight years,
and the number one thing
that influenced that was
interpersonal contact.
That was people knowing a
person who was gay or lesbian
or transsexual, right?
And because of having those
social networks, right?
We've expanded who we
know, and you know,
you don't have the closetedness
as you did in the past.
And so yeah, so that
interpersonal connection is
made, and that was one of
the things that really,
really caused that policy
to move in that direction.
Caused public opinion to move
that direction on that policy.
>> Interesting question,
great question.
I think somebody was
second, right here?
This lady in the second row?
And then we--
>> A lot of these things do
not sound new at all to me,
you can sub-- surmise
that under sensationalism.
And I remember when I was
in middle school we
were educated how
to identify fake news in the
Yellow Press, for instance,
there were some very
easily to identify markers,
where we could see
that, for instance,
the way they use the
language, very emotional,
that there was actually
no information, of course,
no mentioning of sources or so.
Can you imagine that nowadays
kids get being educated in order
to identify fake news in their
social media, and do you think
that is a role that
schools should play?
>> Yes [laughs], information
literacy I think is absolutely
the key to this.
Being able to identify
those things.
Like you said, stories
that are non-sourced.
I mean, there is a
real big flag there.
But we also have this
social media where,
it's very compressed, right?
So you don't expect
a lot of sourcing.
It's difficult to find where
a meme came from, right?
An image with just
information on it.
So absolutely, I think media
literacy is absolutely the main
thing that we need to do.
But I think that part
of that media literacy
as I've stressed here, has
to deal with how we interact
with information, and knowing
and understand how we
can bring our emotions
and our pre-conceived biases
and how we can be easily
fooled by things as well.
So I absolutely agree.
Excellent question.
>> Thank you, Todd.
Very interesting.
In case anybody didn't
know, today the FCC decided
to demolish net neutrality.
What do you see as the impact on
social media by this decision?
>> Great question.
>> This is a really
good question.
And the main concern with net
neutrality is the throttling
issue, right?
And now allowing
so much bandwidth
to certain types of sites.
We saw what happened with
Netflix when they got throttled,
and they ponied up
extra money to be able
to keep their bandwidth open
for their movie streaming.
It is-- obviously Twitter
and Facebook are
extraordinarily successful,
and so they would be
able to ride it out,
but what social media
does for democracy,
it's not the 140
characters that matter,
it's what you're
linking to there.
Right? And so there may
be some of those links
to outside sources that, you
know, you may not be able
to download quite as easily,
and may be silenced from them.
>> If I could just
comment again on that.
>> Yeah.
>> But in other countries,
this has happened before,
and free services, such as
Facebook, Twitter, etc.,
have gone to paid subscriptions,
and have gone into packaging.
Internet service providers
have put together packages,
like your-- like Comcast would,
where you don't have the
premium channels and things.
If people need to start paying
to access Twitter, Facebook
and Instagram, and YouTube,
and things like that,
how do you think that is going
to affect social
media in general?
>> Well obviously that's going
to widen what we call the
digital divide, right?
Between the haves,
and the have nots.
Most people, especially
most people
in foreign countries right now,
use their primary
device their phone.
Right? And so they get a cheap
phone, and they use things
for free, so I think that will
divide us even more in terms
of the haves and have nots, I
think so, and obviously, yeah,
just Ethiopia two days ago
shut down their social media
because they were
having some unrest.
You know, hopefully we don't
do that in this country,
but there are-- net
neutrality is a nefarious way
to privilege some forms of
speech over others, yeah.
>> Gentleman in the
bowtie was next.
>> So I wanted to ask
what you think the role
of platforms should be, and
monitoring, sorry, censoring,
moderating the national
dialogue,
especially when you look at some
political candidates we've had,
and elected officials, where
their platforms border on hate.
And so where, what point
should we say like, nope,
that's not worthy of
your 140 characters,
you're not letting that go up.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Or what, or how should
Facebook or Twitter say like,
this really isn't a
good idea, kind of.
What roles do platforms play?
>> Okay. Thank you
for that question.
Obviously these tech
companies say,
"We're tech companies not
media companies," right?
And they like to sort
of hide behind that
and give themselves a shield.
But they are our
gateway to media, right?
And you know, you're talking
about hate speech and such,
well, that comes under
the terms of service
of each particular
platform, right?
And that is up to each platform.
There are terms of service
and Twitter has actually
been a little bit more strict
than Facebook in terms
of blocking users
for violating their
terms of service.
It is up to them, right?
They are businesses,
and we shouldn't be
telling businesses how
to conduct this type of thing.
But on the other side, right?
They are performing a very,
very important service.
But we don't have like the
FCC licensing that we can hold
over their heads, right?
In order to be able to
do what we want, right?
The internet, it's a
complicated system of, you know,
of interaction, where it's
not all government owned.
It's not all owned by the
people like the airwaves are,
so we can't use the
FCC to do that.
So it's a bit more complicated.
And so it's certainly up
to those, and you know,
you can opt out of a
group that you don't--
of a business for which you
don't like their policies,
but then again, you know,
there's only two
big ones, right?
I mean, well, we've got
four up here, right?
But Instagram for politics?
Eh, kind of not so much, right?
And YouTube?
Eh, kind of not so much.
But it's really Twitter
and Facebook, right?
That's the big fish in the sea.
>> Down in the back there?
>> Hi, I'd like to
offer a little bit
of historical perspective.
I'm doing quality review
on historic newspapers,
and in 1893, one of the
newspapers was like,
what would the world
be like in 1993?
And a journalist was
speculating that aside
from the vast acceleration
of technology not
much philosophically,
and he quoted something
from the 18th Century
which was saying how
horrible newspapers were
with character assassination,
salaciousness, mid-18th Century,
which claimed that around
the turn of the 18th Century,
things were sober and
good, but that was
like 60 years before the 18th
Century gentleman's time,
and the person from the 1893
was looking back and saying
if this person said
it was so bad then,
basically things will
not have changed much
in terms of human nature.
The main changing factor is the
vast acceleration of technology.
Could you trace cyclical
changes in philosophy of news,
or is the primary differential
essentially technological?
>> What do you mean
by philosophy of news?
I'm sorry--
>> I mean trying to report
things relatively objectively
rather than going for sensation.
18th Century, 19th
Century, different periods.
>> Okay. Thank you
for your question.
Obviously there's
always rosy retrospection
about the old times, right?
And we can always complain about
the kids these days, right,
and their social media,
and what's going on,
and I've tried not
to do that here,
and what I've been
talking about.
But I think one of the problems
that social media has created is
that everyone is seen
as a purveyor of news
with equal amount
of credibility.
And I think that is a problem.
And this is not helped
by the fact that the--
that mainstream news
media is pretty reviled
in this country right now, and
are losing their credibility.
There are still more people
who get their information
from television news
than social media,
but that is on the
decline, in concordance
with their credibility.
So that can be a problem.
But there is an important
place for legacy media,
and for curated news,
for fact-checking,
for double-checking
your sources.
CNN got into a little
bit of problem
with that last week,
didn't they, right?
So I think that you know,
there's still a place for that.
It is important, and the
fact that those are still,
as I showed with those bubbles.
The legacy media are still
some of the biggest bubbles
up there that are linked to.
So they play an important role
in the information environment,
and that air of credibility
and their news philosophy
is still very important
to a lot of people.
>> Right here.
>> Hi, I would like you to
comment on the implications
of social media for the
market place in terms
of for example Bloomberg had
a piece a couple of weeks ago,
or whenever Amazon
took over Whole Foods.
Contrasting how many
Trader Joe's customers were
at Whole Foods that day,
and you know, vice-versa,
and so they knew avocados were
driving the issue, for example.
So that was information
aggregated from social media.
So one could assume that a fake
news story could drive a market
price, for example,
a stock price.
That kind of thing.
>> Or an oil price [laughter].
>> Yeah, an oil price.
Do you have any comments on
the commercial implications?
And even Bitcoin, for
example, of social media?
>> Yeah, they are
obviously vast, right?
If you can get a story that
can hook into people's emotions
and can make them panic
about something, right?
We can-- I'm not going to say
we're going to see, you know,
a 1929 situation or
anything like that,
but certainly people really,
you know, gravitate to stories
that make them emotionally
anxious, afraid and worried.
Those types of stories
have been shown
by political science scholarship
to stimulate information
seeking about those things.
But on the flip side, if you're
getting that information,
then you're going to be doing
more information seeking,
then you can sort of find
out what's real about that.
So it is possible, but I hope
that our natural human tendency
in that instance is to seek out
more information and then to get
to the truth, I would hope.
>> You know, one
thing that hasn't come
up directly is the
impact the President,
both when he was
running for President,
and now that he is President,
so what impact has his approach
to social media had that
may be lasting in terms
of electoral strategies,
and in terms of governing.
Is it too soon to
talk about that?
Or what is this-- where is
the scholarship going on that?
You wrote a book about
2016, or part of it--
>> I did about the campaign.
People are writing
about governance now.
>> Yeah, right.
>> So that stuff is still
in process, but the things
that we've seen about
Donald Trump
that he's been effective
at, is remember I said
that politicians use
Twitter to talk to the press?
It's-- there's...it's not
a coincidence that he is
up so early in the
morning Tweeting.
He's trying to set the
media agenda for the day.
He's trying to tell
us what, you know,
we're going to be talking about.
He's trying to tell the
people at the New York Times,
the Washington Post, ABC News,
CNN, what he wants them to cover
that night, by saying
provocative things,
and getting traction on
those particular issues.
I think we will probably see
other people trying to do that.
I don't know if they'll have the
same sort of effect that he has.
Another thing that we've seen
is the name-calling, right?
We see Lying Ted, right?
And Crooked Hillary.
I hope that's not something
we're going to start seeing.
But once you get something
like that attached to you,
it becomes what political
scientists call a
meta narrative.
It becomes really difficult
to break out of, right?
Al Gore never said he
invented the internet, right?
But we have this sort of idea,
that you know, he did say that.
Sarah Palin never
said "I can see Alaska
from my house," right?
But this Saturday Night
Live thing, you know--
>> Russia, yeah.
Russia.
>> I can see-- what did I say?
>> Alaska.
>> Alaska, no.
I can see Russia.
>> She may neve have said that
either but [laughter], right?
>> And Donald Trump
never said, and this went
around during the election,
he never actually said,
"If I ever ran for President
I would run as a republican
because they're the
dumber party."
There was a meme going
around that he said that.
He actually never said that.
That was debunked.
But once you get these sorts
of things attached to you,
it's really difficult
to get through that.
And so this crooked Hillary
thing, really was difficult.
And you know, we saw this in
the Virginia election, right?
He tried to label, Enron
Ed, Ed Gillespie, right?
So we're starting to see
some of this mimicry,
going on in political campaigns.
And it can be effective.
And it does damage
to our discourse.
We're certainly not
talking about policy
when we're name-calling, right?
>> They have a question
over here.
Gentleman over here.
[ Inaudible ]
>> I'm sorry, I can't
hear you, sir.
>> Anxious, afraid
and one other thing?
>> Worried.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> It occurs to me in your
talk that the history really,
the growth of the internet
since the early 90s,
coincides with the
political polarization
and gridlock in Congress.
The disconnect and inability
of Congressional
parties to work together.
And Congress is effectively
broken
and not working as it should.
Do you see any correlation
between the growth
of the information superhighway
as we once called it,
and this new transparency
that brings in,
and this breaking of our system?
>> Thank you for that question.
That is sort of the holy grail
right now of American politics,
that people are trying
to work on.
It is very difficult
to disentangle some
of these things going
on at the same time.
Let me tell you about
some of the other things
that are going on right?
Obviously we have
increased polarization.
There are some really good
charts, that you can see people
who identify strongly
republican, strongly democrat,
nationwide, moving
out towards the poles.
There's also good
information that shows
on the DW Nominate scores
that they use to rank members
of Congress as to
how they're voting.
They're moving out as well.
We also have the
internet, right?
Social media.
We talk about that today.
But we also have what is
called Niche Media, now.
How many channels you
got on your cable now?
Can you find something
that you agree with?
Does everybody have
different options
that they can go
to for their news?
They certainly do.
And the advent of Niche
Media has also done that.
And so some people
have said, you know,
that's part of it as well.
Another thing that is
going on that a recent book
that was written called
"The Big Sort," it talks
about self-sorting, right?
Democrats are moving
to the cities.
Right? Republicans are moving
to suburbs and to rural areas,
and so our amount of
interaction with people
with whom we disagree
with is becoming limited,
and we can de-friend
them on social media.
We don't hold so many dinner
parties anymore, right?
We don't have so many social
groups that we go to, you know,
Elks Lodge, and different
types of social interactions
after work that people used
to have because of that,
so there's a lot
of things going on.
And so disentangling those, and
trying to say what's the chicken
and what's the egg
here, is something
that political scientists
are working on.
We don't have quite the
answer yet, but yes.
Stay tuned.
>> Great question.
We have time for
another question,
I think we have actually
a couple over here.
This gentleman here, and then we
will go over here, so two more.
One, and then two,
then we're done.
>> Hi. Would you also
comment on the volume
of information people
get, you know,
after 24 hours seven days
news, change the landscape
of information, and now they
get, you know, 100 times more
than that and how do they
actually make any sense
of all that?
Isn't that actually pushing
them to hold onto their hatred
or their, you know, fears or
whatnot, to just, you know,
find some sort of
ground in that chaos?
>> Mm, yes it is [laughs].
The fact that we have
the 24 hour news cycle,
and that we have
information going on.
Also causes mainstream press
right, to report things
without fact-checking because
they want to stay ahead
of the cycle as well that
has happened a couple times.
Some things haven't been
double-checked, that they would,
the fact that we
want to, you know,
find things that can just
make us sleep easier, right?
With this whole massive
information coming at us.
And so dealing with those types
of things certainly does make
us a little bit more polarized.
We can even find that if you
look at when people interact
with information with
which they disagree,
they automatically shut off.
Their brain waves are
not as active, as if,
when they see information
that they agree with,
they become more active.
So how do we get past that?
I mean, with this,
this oppressive information all
the time, and then leading us
to seek out the stuff
that we like or is going
to make us comfortable,
and the answer actually is
to find common ground
with other people.
When you start with a premise
that you and somebody else agree
on the same thing, right?
The end goal, then you can keep
somebody in a conversation.
Then you can start talking
about how we get to that goal,
and what the means are.
But social media, right?
We're not having those long,
protracted conversations.
We're having little
bits and bytes.
That's something I think
we need to work on.
>> Gentleman over here,
with the last question?
>> Since we are at the
Library of Congress today,
I'm going to finish up with
a library question for you.
All right, to support your
work or scholars like you,
or more importantly
future scholars like you,
what do you see in the role
of archives, libraries,
and memory institutions
with regard to social media?
>> Okay, that is a
fantastic question.
>> Did you put that question in?
>> I did not [laughter].
>> Appreciate it if you did.
>> I didn't.
The obviously the holdings are
extensive here at the library,
and some of the holdings are,
especially the digital holdings,
are held by others, right?
Proquest, and such.
One of the things that
the library could do
to help scholars like myself is
to develop an institutional
capacity
for extracting and
aggregating data.
One of the things I've had a
little bit of difficulty is
if I would like to be able
to say okay, for my project,
from 1960 to 2016, I want
every op ed page from this time
to this time, and to be
able to have that extracted
so I can put together a
data set, then sample off
that data set, and do
that sort of thing.
So I think building
some more capacity.
Because what the
library has is fantastic.
I think getting our fingers
into it, and getting it out in
such a way, where we can
make it useful, I think,
is the one place
that needs some work.
>> Well, thank you again,
Todd, was very interesting.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.